they'll make a girl of promise if you
know you can't keep it
hallo the Master Chief collection is an
infamous example of one of Microsoft's
blunders this console generation what
should have been an easy win as a
celebration of their biggest franchise
went sour after massive launch issues
that plagued everything from multiplayer
to the campaigns patches fixed the large
problems but the Master Chief collection
was never fully fixed to a level that
both the fans and three-for-three
themselves were happy with so it's kind
of insane that now almost four years
later 343 is returning to deliver a
massive update this summer promising an
overhaul to the matchmaking and visual
changes so to understand why this is
such a big deal we need to look back at
just how much of a mess the Master Chief
collection was at launch and how three
four three plans to fix it back at e3
2014 343 announced halo the Master Chief
collection it would poured over halo one
two three and four to the Xbox one and
get them running at 1080p 60 frames a
second
halo 2 would get remastered visuals the
same way halo combat Evolved did three
years earlier and perhaps most
meaningful of all all of these games
multiplayers would come over as well not
only could you seamlessly switch from a
match in Halo 3 to halo 4
but halo tubes multiplayer would return
after the original Xbox Live shutdown in
2010 and halo ones multiplayer would be
available on Xbox Live for the first
time this was an incredible value and
should have been a strong start to Halo
4 this console generation however once
the game was released problems cropped
up almost immediately for starters right
out launched there was no dedicated
playlist available for halo combat
Evolved 343 said they were holding off
until network performance for that
particular game was running smooth they
should have been a warning sign for
things to come as it quickly became a
minor point when matchmaking issues
began to crop up for every game in the
collection our Plus long wait times for
matches or failing to connect at all
became common for a lot of people other
issues extended into the campaign such
as in game freezes audio issues and
other bugs documented by fans it wasn't
a promising start but 343 responding
quickly with a number of server-side
updates to improve matchmaking days
after launch along with an apology from
the head of the studio these
improvements however were inconsistent
working on some players with others
still stuck in long matchmaking loading
times in a blog update just four days
after launch it was stated that recent
patches had shown a 20% increase in
server connectivity and that larger
issues would be fixed in a patch planned
for release on the 19th and yet despite
the massive list of issues this patch
was supposed to correct large number of
players didn't feel the effects and
we're still stuck without being able to
connect reliably what's worse is the
patch even added new UI bugs so fast
forward a few weeks in several apologies
later in a brand new patch is released
designed to finally fix the issues the
previous patch didn't and this one
actually stuck fixing a whole host of
matchmaking issues and getting things in
a stable state they were even able to
bring back playlist modes like SWAT
which had been removed right after
launch in an effort to help with
matchmaking finally a month after launch
the Master Chief collection was a
reliable product not perfect mind you
there was still a whole host of issues
and patches were regularly pushed out
all the way up until April 2015 but
despite all these improvements that
broke in first month severely hurt the
Master Chief collection z' reputation
many left before the game was fixed into
a playable state and even after it was
playable the damage was already done in
an effort to make it up to the fans
three-for-three added for free both halo
4 Spartan Ops mode and the entire
campaign of Halo 3 ODST the latter of
which was never originally planned for
the collection but was high on the list
of what fans wanted and made a very good
worse re-gift eventually things calm
down with the Master Chief collection
and once halo fives release began to
ramp up the update slowed down and
eventually stopped the Master Chief
collection became a painful mark on
343's history with Frank O'Connor
calling it a black eye for the studio
343 promised every future Halo game
would have a beta and more extensive
testing to make sure this never happened
again there's no real way of knowing
what the population of the collection
was like in the years sense there are
those hardcore fans that stuck with it
and played regularly and you have the
occasional fan that would pop in for a
match every once in a while
plateless ended up feeling a little
sparse and unreliable though you had a
much better chance of getting into a
match in team Slayer than you did on
just the halo 1 playlist where there
were kind of like the same ten people
over and over again but while the game
has been largely fixed and in good shape
for years there are still lingering
issues back in January of 2017 community
manager Brian jarred said on reddit that
conversations were still being had at
the studio about the possibility of
future updates that opportunity came in
the form of the launch of the Xbox one X
Microsoft's updated console that
supports 4k in October of 2017 three
years after the game's release 343
announced the Master Chief collection
would be getting an Xbox 1x enhanced
update it was looking at when we look at
Xbox 1x it's an opportunity to take our
current gen portfolio and enhance it
across to give a better play experience
that looks better on everything we're
doing and matched a massive collection
should definitely be part of that so
this is the time that we're going to
crack it open move it over to the latest
game operating system which has amazing
improvements to matchmaking which will
benefit from and now it's the right time
and we're pretty excited that we're
gonna move the whole portfolio forward
On January 31st 2018 Brian Jared also
known as sketch started a series of
development blogs on the Master Chief
collection update project if you're
someone who is interested in this update
these are definitely worth reading as
343 is very open and transparent on the
development and their plans for the
update on the backend the game's
matchmaking api's will be updated to the
current standard of xbox live which
should improve overall matchmaking and
make parties more reliable this will
also require an update to the
collections 8 separate engines so that
4k support and other visual enhancements
can be made there are also plenty of
exciting features to look forward to
such as Xbox 1x support including 4k
resolution and HDR offline land support
the ability to install each game
individually for those that only prefers
some of the games or have a restrictive
bandwidth there also updating the UI
with a brand new title screen and main
menu to take advantage of 4k and tweak
it for a better user experience all of
this plus a bunch of smaller
quality-of-life improvements such as a
replacement of the voting system which
is meant to address the issue of
everyone voting for only
three maps right now and 343 is planning
for further updates in the future such
as adding a custom game browser akin to
how halo seee
and halo to work on PC they've even
asked people what new features they'd
want to see in future updates the
biggest request being Halo Reach and ODS
T's firefight mode and while these
aren't planned for this current update
or even confirmed to be happening 343
has made it clear that they are aware
people want this and are looking into
the possibilities the other thing people
have been asking for years is for the
Master Chief collection to make its way
to PC which was given a similar response
however an interesting wrinkle in all
this is the recent drama around halo
online which actually happened during
the middle of editing this video the
short version is back in 2015 Microsoft
put out a closed beta for a free-to-play
version of Halo threes multiplayer in
Russia known as halo online the game was
cancelled in August of 2016 El Dorado is
a mod that has been keeping the game
alive removing the region barrier and
continuing to tweak and improve it being
built using microsoft own assets the
recent popularity of el dorado prompted
microsoft to start sending takedown
notices and even bans on twitch in
youtube obviously this didn't go over
well with the community and it's clear
from the popularity and outcry over el
dorado along with official releases like
halo 5 forge showing that there is a
large audience that wants halo 4 the PC
and three for three's official response
they said one thing remains clear the
community really wants more halo on PC
as we look ahead we're very excited
about the prospects of an official
classic halo experience making its way
to PC and we hope we'll be able to
partner with the eldorado team and
broader mod and content creation
community to help inform the types of
experiences and features our fans desire
while we have nothing to announce today
please know that the PC community is
very important to us and top of mind as
we work towards the future that part was
actually tweeted by the head of Xbox
Phil Spencer so all of this points to
ain't in the works project to bring
classic halo to pc whether this means
bringing the Master Chief collection to
PC or something else entirely is pure
speculation but the timing of all this
plus the summer release date for the
Master Chief collection update makes it
hard to not put two and two together but
regardless of all that this
is clearly more than a simple update
adding Xbox 1x support the amount of
effort put towards this update shows
that 343 really cares about fixing the
game and Microsoft still considers halo
and important enough of a property to
let them do it it's also a statement on
the way games are being treated nowadays
publishers and developers are sticking
the games longer adding new content and
improving the experience something that
started as a failure can still be turned
around
who knows if that'll be the case with
the Master Chief collection though again
this update is coming out almost four
years after its release and while I'm
sure there'll be a bump in the player
count when the update launches who knows
how long those people will actually
stick around for the patch is currently
being tested by members of the community
in a closed alpha referred to as a
flight so we'll start to get an idea
soon on how the hardcore fans feel about
it
30,000 people signed up for the flight
program which compared to a lot of the
big games nowadays shows how small halos
community has gotten you also have to
start to wonder how the eventual halo 6
will play into all this with the Master
Chief collection halo 5 + halo 6 the
halo community will be stretched pretty
thin you have to wonder even with all
this effort if it's really gonna do much
for the Master Chief collection halo as
a whole is in a really weird place right
now and it's hard to say for certain
what the future of the series will be
but I have to commend 343 for being
persistent in fixing their mistakes and
being open and transparent with their
community they're on the right path and
maybe just maybe 343 and Microsoft can
turn one of their biggest blunders this
generation into a success but we won't
find out until the update releases later
this summer go make a girl of promise
if you know you can't keep
[Music]